Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie if you guys didn't
know Emilia Clarke from Game Of Thrones was
cast in the Star Wars Han Solo film as the
female lead.
So this is going to be my reaction.
I'll explain what's going on and how this
is going to affect Game Of Thrones Season
8.
So we heard about this the other day you might've
noticed that nobody was talking about who
she is playing because Lucasfilm is keeping
that really close to the vest.
I think for one big reason is that it's some
big change from the established cannon like
they said that they got rid of the EU or most
of the EU so they could do new things with
the films that means that she might be playing
a character that we've never seen before like
a completely original character or she might
be a recast younger version of a character
the we already know really well like Princess
Leia, but I don't think that's the case I
think the whole idea with this Han Solo film
is to tell the story of how he won the Millennium
Falcon from Lando Calrissian who is being
played by Donald Glover with two I think they're
also trying to tell the story of how he and
Chewbacca came together in the story of how
Chewbacca came to have the life debt, but
largely the story of how Han Solo one the
Millennium Falcon was in a soapbox game.
So imagine James Bond in a smugglers version
of Casino Royale playing that epic poker game
but he winds up winning the Falcon because
Lando doesn't have enough to cover his bets
the story of how Chewbacca came to be Han
Solo's copilot of the money and Falcon story
of the life that they might weave in a lot
of clone wars stuff because technically clone
wars is so Canada Star Wars.
They didn't throw that out like that through
the rest of the EU out.
So once we get some more details, we can talk
a little bit more about that but what about
Game Of Thrones because Emilia Clarke if you
can be the female lead of this Han Solo movie.
They start shooting in January.
What does that say for Game Of Thrones season
8 the good news is that it shouldn't have
any effect at all because of winter.
So on Game Of Thrones this past season one
of the big problems filming was they had to
wait for things to get colder because in the
world of Game Of Thrones winter has come so
the need to reflect that in all the filming
that they do so they just waited till later
in the year till it was actually winter in
some of the places they were filming in Europe.
So typically what they've done in previous
seasons as they just are shooting during the
summer and they shoot all the way up towards
the end of November early December.
So this year they waited a couple more months
films a little bit later in the year but they'd
still be done filming for her to do Han Solo
in January.
And even though could take up to six months
to film a really big Star Wars film she would
still be done in time to start filming Game
Of Thrones season eight on time just keep
in mind that the gonna be doing the exact
same thing next year with season eight though
start filming later in the year they'll be
fewer episodes, so they won't film quite as
much but each of the episodes that they film
will be much bigger this like a whole other
video about them filming season eight because
it will be hardcore winter by the time that
starts but Emilia Clarke in a Star Wars movie
this is a huge deal.
I would save all the Game Of Thrones actors
that I would love to see in the Star Wars
film she's somewhere near the middle of you
like Lena heat he is a better actress, but
the thing is is this is a movie about a younger
Han Solo like a twentysomething Han Solo if
you imagine that he's like a thirtysomething
Han Solo when the original trilogy picks up
so you have to cast an actress that has like
age, parity with Alden Ehrenreich who's playing
Han Solo, so a lot of your wondering maybe
this is Han Solo's wife from before he met
Princess Leia.
I don't think that's who she's playing because
she's an African-American character so don't
if the gonna whitewash that her name is Sana
Starros another big thing on the fan wish
list is Ahsoka in the movies.
A lot of you are asking me maybe she's playing
Ahsoka.
The thing about that is that I think will
eventually see her somewhere in the spinoff
films but I think it's much more likely that
Ahsoka would show up during the Obi Wan spinoff
film is because she Obi Wan and Vader go hand-in-hand
and Han Solo didn't really encounter that
many Jedi before he met Luke and Obi Wan on
tattooing the story of the original trilogy
like and when we get to episode 7 says the
force it's all true like it took him a long
time to get to that point.
I don't think there can be a lot of Jedi or
even Darth Vader in this Han Solo movie.
So my thought is is that it's more likely
that she's a Jyn Erso type character someone
who's really big but brand-new and original
to this film.
So let me know in the comments what you guys
think about Emilia Clarke in this Star Wars
Han Solo movie.
And who do you think that she is playing just
go keep in mind that they're not doing a lot
of expanded universe stuff, so she's probably
not one of those characters and keep in mind
that if she's this age.
During this Han Solo movie that she would
also be like Princess Leia age during Star
Wars episode seven, so should be like a really
old lady standing somewhere in the background
here if she still alive in the new films.
But as we learn more about the film I'll do
more video so be sure to subscribe for more
Han Solo videos I think people will be a little
bit more excited about the Han Solo film than
they are about Rogue one just because of the
characters that they're doing what they're
doing the big characters so if you like the
level of fascination is just gonna be that
much greater because even though stealing
the plans for the Death Star is a really big
deal most of the characters during Rogue one
are actually pretty new think the performance
of Rogue one at the box office will largely
determine how they tune the other spinoff
films like how much of the old character should
we put in these other films which film should
we be doing like do we do a Yoda films we
do a Boba Fett film do we do and Obi Wan film
I actually think it's more likely that they
would do a Yoda film in Obi-Wan Kenobi before
they would do Boba Fett, just depending on
the tone that they want to go with that's
another big thing which other big films you
want them to do next because this Han Solo
movie will kind of fill the gap between Star
Wars episode eight in episode 9.
So will get that next spinoff films after
episode not to that's a long ways off.
They have a long time to figure it out but
I do feel like Obi-Wan Kenobi would be like
the solid pick for like the next big film
to do.
But new Walking Dead posting later tonight
and then I'll do my Westworld video just like
last week it seem like anybody was happy with
the Westworld video that I did, so I'll keep
doing that for the rest of the season so while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my Star Wars Episode 8 video and
you can click here for all my Game Of Thrones
Season 6 and Season 7 videos thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight!